[Music]
I know I already reviewed the force
awakens as a sibling rivalry for
Disney's ember but a few years have gone
by and even more Star Wars movies have
come out so I think it makes sense to
look back and see if it still holds up
force awakens is the first Star Wars
movie that pretty much had no input from
George Lucas after he sold Star Wars to
Disney the thing about it is it's
probably the Star Wars movie that plays
it the most safe yet somehow also still
takes a few risks
the story is years later the Empire are
gone but the first order is now in
charge a let's just say it another
Empire they didn't even change the store
trooper clothes you'll find there's a
lot of repeating in this though as a
droid has some information about the
first order that could be incredibly
helpful an escape pilot named Poe and a
next-door trooper named Finn escaped the
first order and get to what a shock a
desert planet they come across a poor
young person who doesn't know her family
and coins identity happens to be really
strong with the force and she's being
hunted by a dark mass entity the race is
on to get the droid to the rebellion
while also getting help from han Solo
and Chewie Wow didn't even need to
change the names on that one so yeah as
everyone has said before this is pretty
much a retread of new hope and I'd be
lying if I said I wasn't exactly a big
fan of that well what actually happens
in the movie is a little too familiar
the set up is actually kind of different
details that some fans might find
upsetting other fans find actually kind
of intriguing and good at continuing the
story
for example Han Solo and Princess Leia
are no longer together
and I'll keep the spoiler free but if
you know how a new hope goes you know
there's a definite well it's not exactly
a shocker it is still kind of a risky
move the original Star Wars trilogy
combined a lot of different elements of
myth and fairy tales and folklore and
philosophy and religion all these
different things feeling though is
mostly fairy tale it's a happy ending
the people who should be together are
together the people who should be dead
or dead the people who should be alive
or alive and they're all happy this
definitely throws a wrench in that fairy
tale and people are either gonna love
that or hate it
for me Oh like the idea that I can just
accept the original three movies as they
are and then see this as kind of another
continuation that I don't have to accept
if I want I can just say it and didn't
return the
what if other movies are gonna continue
this is not a bad way to continue them
the I'd be lying if I said I didn't
really want the book versions to make it
to the big screen but for something
entirely original which I can see why
they want to do that too and I guess
this makes sense it's kind of like
comparing the doom books the first ones
about the coming of the Messiah and he
comes and brings balance in the second
one reality sets it and you find out
it's not all that simple well I see the
charm and even sometimes the importance
of the fairytale ending at the same time
I do like questioning happily ever after
I do like saying what happens when real
life gets in the way how do you confront
it how do you win it can you win it what
happens when you fail these are more
interesting questions that I feel can
help people along with life but it also
still keeps them mythos fantasy angle
and yeah I have to be honest it's the
first Star Wars movie since probably
returned the Jedi that really felt like
Star Wars the bench of the Sith came
close but it was still a little too
modern Luca see this had a lot of
practical effects this had a lot of dirt
on everything this had stuff that was
really there and aliens with interesting
identities and people with interesting
identities and they were charming and
they were funny
they had mystery set up they had
villains that were complex I want to see
where everything was going with these
characters and as I said my nostalgia
crate review I think that's why there
was so much repeating to show that they
can do a Star Wars movie this is Disney
now Lucas is gone they want to show that
they can do this right but again there
are still just enough risks taken that
it did keep my interest and I did want
to know where the movies were going if I
saw any of the prequels on their own I
wouldn't care what was in the next film
but if I saw this on its own I would
have to know what happens next one of
the things that surprised me the most
about this movie was Harrison Ford as
Han Solo I don't know how to put this
nicely but the past few years Harrison
Ford hasn't exactly been that amazing an
actor it always feels like he's trying
to overcompensate he's trying to act
super tough to show that he hasn't been
away for too long he's not too old and
so you just kind of see the balm of his
teeth jutting out and him acting really
mad and it always felt kind of phony but
here he's han Solo and he's older and
he's great and he's hilarious and he's
smart and he's just he's a really great
character in this the rest of the acting
is really good
to kylo Ren if you were to describe this
villain to me I would think would not be
a particularly strong character but the
way he's played and written he is so
complex he is so interesting he is so
torn you want to help this guy out you
wanted to be accepted but at the same
time he's done so many terrible things
and will continue to do terrible things
and you just go back and forth with him
which is what I feel you should do with
a villain like this I'll admit it is a
little weird watching and now knowing
the direction a lot of these films go I
do remember canthus excitement when the
film started and we were back in Star
Wars but now that we're getting one
sometimes even two a year I'd be lying
if I said the size and magnitude of this
movie hasn't gone down a little bit but
watching it years later it still has a
lot of atmosphere a lot of great effects
a lot of charm a lot of jokes a lot of
great characters it's still not only a
decent Star Wars movie but just a good
movie overall it's entertaining it's
action-packed it's got some great effect
it's got a lot of imagination now the
more we do get is kind of a different
story and we'll get to that soon but for
this film watching eight years later
it's kind of like meeting up with an old
friend again and a perfect friend but
still a friend nonetheless
[Music]
you